today I'm launching the new bad boys
bakery lemon treacle slice as a
marketing ploy I've invited 50 catering
industry VIPs including major players
from the coffee shop sector to lunch I'm
hoping to seduce these potential
commercial partners with the food before
trying to interest them in stock in the
slice for the prisoners today's
government test I mean is it's not gonna
get any bigger than this but everything
they've learned something they've seen
tasted done it's got to go into those
plates today my team have to be at the
top of the game for the lunch to go to
plan but I'm not the only one worried
about drug dealer Haas and or former
heroin addict David Jones isn't happy
I've paired them up you're really never
sure all right working with David is
changing the way how Sam feels about his
career choices the first time I'm John
abundant I'm friends with people
actually taking cross a joke and it's
laughs I feel sorry for them but it's
crazy that movie would disregard these
people are crackheads and [ __ ]
so enough to do take back we don't know
what they went through their life I'm
sure
and there's people like me and other
people I sell jobs that benefit from me
I mean it touched a nerve they made me
say to myself I'm never gonna sell
prostate drugs ever again in my life
reaching more guys before I unveiled the
bad boy bakery's new flagship product
this bunch of misfits have three courses
of restaurant-quality food to get out
service has to be impeccable you guys
are cooking for esteemed guests today
around the chapel five tables you can
see the stations you're literally a
meter away from them so if I see any
[ __ ] with anyone standing they're
gassing away hey my five man how you
doing I swear to god I'm gonna come
behind you and remind you okay yes you
can do it let's go let's go let's go
today is a massive occasion for the
prisoner for me and for my team the
nerves are already getting to Andrew
easily and Anthony Kelly
they've over-seasoned that does enough
squash soup Inslee and Kelly I don't
have to start all over again there's a
big test for these guys it's a massive
test and rains these flipping out and
you know getting really nervous
how do you taste it you don't taste that
any pain are you telling me I have to
change it
like for me I believe now when I gotta
tell I can be something
what Gordon's done is he's put that five
in people's bellies to make people want
to do something and when we get out to
think yeah we can do this I actually
can't do it
Seiler sports town to impress the guest
it's vital the food looks as good as it
tastes Hassan has decided to take his
Wellington but spelling isn't his strong
point
I just wanted to do so different I
wouldn't know that when it comes up that
is my penis David
let's get guys please the VIP guests
have started to arrive they run some of
the UK's most successful restaurant
chains and coffee businesses
they've got the clout to help me take
the slice to market well my gut feeling
is the public would respond really
positively you know especially if it was
branded
Brixton prison that's my gut feeling
it's quite an interesting project and a
tall order yeah it might be might be
something that we're interested in
one guess that really don't want to
upset has found his way down to the
kitchen plugin impressive does that
would you do right and at the prison
service okay yeah
five minutes guys Yona vote one shot is
a lot of speak papa
I thought these talking out come on the
streets a lot of speed but what I'll
preserve myself proper properly guys
quickly come over when we go up there
the room is gonna be full
this is your one freaking chance to rise
above in prison
rise above it so give them some charm
let's go guys